So we're seeing,
uh,
you know,
if you'd look now at what are the big drivers of,
uh,
infectious diseases right now in the,
in,
in not only in the US,
but globally,
there really some interesting forces.
And a lot of them are social determinants.
So a big one is poverty.
That's,
that's a huge one.
The other big one is political instability in war because it interrupts public
health control measures.
So for instance,
Venezuela,
which was leading public health control and Latin America for decades,
you know,
with the collapse of the economy in,
in the,
in the Chavez era now until the Madora area Madora area,
we've got a terrible situation where,
uh,
we've had measles return in a big way.
So huge numbers of cases of measles.
We fed all of the neglected tropical diseases come back,
uh,
as well as malaria,
chagas disease,
leishmaniasis.
So it's really interesting how that is destabilizing the whole region because
now Venezuela has one of the largest diaspora is of people as big as the
diaspora coming out of Syria and Iraq.
So now that the diseases are moving into adjacent areas of Brazil and Colombia
and Ecuador.
And so it's really,
and that's another big drivers,
political instability.
The third one,
uh,
we think is climate change may be very important.
So,
you know,
why did we see this big a surge of chicken gunyah virus infection in the western
hemisphere or Zika?
We don't really understand the forces of that.
And what's going on in southern Europe right now is quite concerning.
We've had malaria returned to Greece,
uh,
after it's been gone for 70 years.
Malaria's returned to Italy.
We're seeing schistosomiasis and neglected tropical disease on the island of
Corsica.
We've got,
uh,
Danky,
chicken Gunyah West Nile virus across Italy,
Spain,
Portugal.
So we're trying to understand why that is.
And there's some thought that climate change may be a big driver of that.
Now,
what other infectious diseases or parasites rather,
do they have vaccines for two,
they have a vaccine for Toxo,
which there's no vaccine for toxoplasmosis.
Um,
there's a,
a prototype malaria vaccine that's,
yeah,
well it's,
it's an,
it's a VA.
There's a malaria vaccine.
It's called Moscow.
Rick's.
That's the trade name that was developed,
uh,
supported button with a lot of funding from the bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation.
And,
uh,
working in partnership with glaxosmithkline.
And that malaria vaccine now has been approved for use in children by the
European medicine agency.
And it's being introduced now in three countries in Africa,
Malawi,
Ghana.
And I forgot the third one.
I think it was tense.
Is there an adverse reaction that people have that that's tough.
Cause I know the traditional malaria medication,
I had friends that took it and had horrible nightmares.
Oem Larry M is terrible.
Yeah.
Gives you very lurid dreams and yeah know.
And so far,
no.
And there,
when you say children,
how old are the children that they're at vaccinating ending with this?
Well,
the problem that you get into with malaria is that before six months of age,
you have maternal antibodies and board.
You remember the word you're born with,
antibodies from your mother.
And those start to wane by six months of age.
So the ones who get hospitalized with measles was what's called cerebral
malaria,
which is a devastating condition or a severe malaria anemia,
which is also a killer.
Are those children between six months of age and five years of age.
So those are the ones that we want to protect now.
And it's one of the leading killers of children globally.
Right.
And we don't have the vaccine is sickle cell is connected to a crack,
right?
Sickle cell is,
it has something to do with,
uh,
people developing an immunity to malaria.
Yeah,
that's it.
I'm surprised you knew that and it not from Tiffany Haddish who's Tiffany had
it.
How dare you?
She's a very funny comedian.
Um,
I'm sure she is,
but she's,
well,
she's told me it's like,
wow,
it's not really immunity,
but it's a natural protection.
So individuals who have the sickle cell trait are seem to be partially resistant
to malaria.
And that's the thinking why the gene for sickle cell has been preserved in
Africa for so long is because it does confer some protection against malaria.
So it's a reason for keeping the gene and the gene pool.
Yeah,
we were actually discussing it because a friend that I grew up with died from
it.
Um,
so it seems to only exist in African Americans or Africans.
Is that correct?
Predominant.
Now there's some other places as well,
but predominantly places an African and among African Americans or people whose
ancestors came from these tropical climates where they price.
Yeah.
So it's pretty,
it's really quite an amazing story.
So,
um,
there's no,
no,
no.
Um,
vaccine for toxoplasmosis.
Is there anything on the horizon?
Is there anything we worked on because that's a big one,
right?
It's a real big problem on people with HIV aids for instance.
That's a,
because it reactivates your toxoplasmosis and we even see it in,
I even see it in kids sometimes,
but the thing is activated.
How so?
Well,
what happens is,
um,
it's in some countries up to 30% of people are actually infected with
toxoplasma.
And the parasite has the ability to undergo a dormancy state in the body until
your immune system gets compromised,
either because of aids or because if you get some kind of medicine that
suppresses your immune system and then it can reactivate it and cause what's
called cerebral toxoplasmosis,
which is quite serious.
So most people handle or toxoplasmosis very well,
you know,
you,
you die with it and don't even know you have it.
But in some cases it gets reactivated.
Right now there doesn't seem to be a lot of incentive for developing a
toxoplasmosis most as vaccine.
Although I'd be very interested to,
to work on something like why would they be no incentive?
It's such a large scale disease.
It's hundreds of millions of people worldwide.
Right?
That's right.
And part of the problem is we have almost no information and the actual number
of people who have it and how extensive it is.
So we call that disease burden.
We don't have good disease burden estimates of toxoplasmosis tested.
I've had a bunch of cats and I'm at feral cats.
Yeah,
you preach and I'm crazy.
A good chance here.
Your are infected,
but as long as your immune system's intact,
then you're okay.
Now,
there is a,
uh,
a related disease that from cats called toxic crisis,
and that's a parasitic worm infection we're finding in the United States among
the poor.
And that's a weren't.
So what happens is if you go into poor neighborhoods,
you know,
and,
uh,
you see a lot of feral cats and dogs and poor neighborhoods,
almost a hundred percent of them have this warm in their intestines and they're
seeding the environment with eggs in their feces.
And the feces are spread all over the poor neighborhoods.
Kids come into contact with them,
and the worm has the ability to migrate through the brain and cerebral toxic
crisis.
Um,
and I think it's an important cause of developmental delays.
It's one of those neglected diseases in the u s and talk about in the book.
And there's no vaccine for that.
He was no vaccine for.
And we didn't have very little awareness about it.
Wow.
Yeah.
I've never even heard of it until just now.
So this is not rare.
I mean,
in some cases,
you know,
up to 10% of certain populations,
like African,
African Americans living in poverty are infected with it.
And it's primarily pets or does it,
is it rodents as well?
Mostly stray dogs.
And it's not even pets.
It's mostly straight dogs and cats.
And,
and I get,
and this is an example of a neglected tropical disease.
Here's,
here's a disease of up to 10% of African Americans living in poverty in the
United States and almost nobody is studying.
Wow.
Right?
And it can affect the way your mind functions.
And it's been linked now to developmental delays.
So,
you know,
everybody wants to know why,
kids living in poverty have developmental delays and people just assume it's
because they live in deprived environments and that sort of thing.
But I think toxic crisis is an important underlying reason for it.
Um,
and this is an example of a neglected disease.
You know,
we,
I mean,
everybody's heard of Ebola,
right?
And everyone's worried about Ebola and,
and the truth is he is never going to come to the United States.
Why is it ever going to be,
cause it's too difficult to transmit.
Um,
unless you have a complete collapse in the health system.
We're never going to have Ebola epidemics in the United States,
but here's a disease of 10% of African Americans living in poverty and no one's
heard of it and there's no incentive to study it.
So that's why I'm trying to raise awareness about these poverty related
diseases.
And that's correct.
I mean,
I don't understand why people don't talk about that one.
That one seems insane,
right?
Yeah,
absolutely.
It's a no brainer.
Right?
And then so,
but you know,
it's very hard to get people to care about diseases of poverty.
I mean,
and this is one of the striking things about when I wrote the book was,
you know,
I've had a lot of success getting people to care about neglected tropical
diseases in Africa and worked with the U S agency for International Development
to support a package of medicines that's now being administered over a billion
people annually.
And that,
you know,
it was one of my proudest accomplishments is,
is helping to raise awareness about neglected tropical disease.
Like we've been talking about a hook and schistosomiasis in Africa,
Asia,
Latin America.
But the minute I talk about poverty related diseases in the u s the lights go
up.
Why is it,
I don't know.
I can't,
I can't figure out what I'm doing wrong.
I've had so much success getting people to care about NTDs,
neglected tropical diseases and poor developing countries.
But you know,
there's been no response to this,
this book.
I mean,
it is a,
um,
and,
and the estimates that I come up on the booker,
we have 12 million Americans live in poverty with a neglected tropical disease,
toxic Darius.
This is one of them.
Another one is chagas disease and the list goes on.
And it's been very hard to get people to care about the poor in this country.
That's very strange to me.
And I've always said that about the way we treat other countries where we want
to send them aid and rebuild these countries.
But we don't do anything about these terrible communities that have been
terrible in this country for decades upon decades.
Right.
And so I try to make the point,
the world has changed,
you know,
this,
this old norm of global health developed versus developing.
It still exists,
but it's going away where what we're seeing is our general arise,
uh,
and all,
all economies.
I mean,
some African countries have eight or 9% economic growth,
but it's all leaving behind a bottom segment of society.
And so I don't care where you show me poverty,
whether it's in Texas or Alabama or Nigeria or Bangladesh.
I will show you these poverty related diseases.
And you know,
I,
I know,
um,
uh,
what's her name?
AOC.
Uh,
the congresswoman from New York has,
uh,
talked a little bit about hookworm and Alabama.
So last time I was in Washington I dropped off a copy of the book in our office,
but no response yet.
Well,
she's probably pretty busy too.
Yeah,
she's doing a lot of other stuff.
You had a magic wand and a,
someone said you could do whatever you want to fix this.
What would you do?
So,
um,
I,
I did meet with a couple of people on the hill and they asked me that question.
What's the magic wand?
And,
um,
there's a couple of things.
One,
we need to actually look for these diseases because the problem is there.
The,
the disease,
they cause a very subtle like developmental delays.
So that if you're a,
you know,
a kid who lives in poverty with developmental delays,
the pediatrician doesn't even think to do a test for toxic crisis.
So that Wa,
so we need to raise awareness.
We need to go into poor communities across the country and actually take a blood
test and actually measure for the presence of that disease or that parasite.
Once you find that disease,
what would you do that?
Well,
it depends the disease.
In some cases we have treatments for him.
Like the treatment for toxic crisis is a five day course of a simple pill of how
Ben dissolve and it cures it and it cures it.
So,
yeah,
so that we have,
you know,
we have interventions.
So one,
you know,
doing what I call active surveillance,
looking for these diseases.
The other one is really trying to understand how these diseases are transmitted.
What is it about poor neighborhoods that is facilitating transmission?
I think the third problem is the diagnostic test themselves because they're very
complicated tests.
Sometimes,
you know,
they are done at the Centers for Disease Control and prevention.
Um,
our lab or National School of Tropical Medicine does a few of them,
but it's not like,
you know,
when you go for a,
you go for blood work and your doctor and you get a little lab slip from quest
diagnostics with the,
you know,
the blood chemistries,
the blood counts,
there's no box there for toxic and chagas disease.
So we need more,
uh,
improved test point of care,
diagnostic tests.
Not just improved tasks but just letting you make it more accessible.
Yeah.
And so they don't have to send it off to the CDC or to,
you know,
our National School of tropical medicine.
Is there a treatment for Toxo?
There is a treatment for toxoplasmosis.
What is it?
Um,
it's a para method means Sulfa drug.
But it requires a long treatment course.
How long?
Uh,
I'd have to look up the number of days.
I haven't treated a patient with toxoplasmosis in a while,
but,
and it kills it effectively.
It can.
Yeah.
Really?
Oh,
I thought it was something you kept for live well,
if you don't get treated right.
Okay.
And then if you're immune compromised and it comes back then that that's a
problem as well.
So most people that have it really don't even know they have it actually.
And most people who have neglected tropical diseases don't know they have it
either.
So that any,
in Texas for instance,
we have transmission of a parasitic disease called chagas disease.
It's a cause of heart disease.
Um,
we,
you know,
our family members of our faculty are,
we're actually able to track down individuals who had donated blood.
Uh,
and the Gulf Coast Regional Blood Authority actually found,
uh,
somebody po people positive for chagas disease.
They are told to go see your primary healthcare provider.
Uh,
and there are unfortunately the primary healthcare providers not educated about
these diseases and they just assume must be a false positive.
So,
you know,
our faculty attract them down and we're able to get them into treatment.
And what is a treatment for chocolates?
It's,
um,
it's a,
an anti parasitic agent called bins nit is all,
and that kills it.
That can kill if you catch it early enough,
but sometimes you don't catch it early.
So if it becomes systemic,
then you have,
then that's why we're trying to develop a therapeutic vaccine for this disease.
But again,
it's a therapeutic vaccine for a poverty related disease.
So it's very tough,
man.
So the point is these diseases are widespread among the poor and we just don't
pay attention to them.
That's great.
It's,
and so I think,
you know,
again,
love to hear your thoughts.
I mean,
what is it that,
um,
we just turn our backs on the port in this country.
It's,
uh,
it's disturbing.
It's very disturbing as a dismissive attitude and they disproportionately affect
people of color as well,
right?
Because,
um,
you know,
it because it's so linked to poverty.
Well also write slavery.
Yeah.
I mean,
I mean the history of slavery in this country.
Then the,
the history of systemic racism in places where they just literally would not
sell homes to people who are African American.
All these things are connected to the,
the,
the contribution of maintaining these impoverished communities.
And there's been almost no effort whatsoever other than the people living in the
community trying to do better and raise everybody up.
There's been no effort whatsoever by the federal government to step in and try
to rehabilitate like a large scale approach to rehabilitating places like the
ghettos of Houston or Baltimore or Detroit.
You know,
I thought I knew what poverty living on I was before I moved to Texas in 2011 I
was chair of microbiology at George Washington University and I thought,
I thought I knew what poverty looked like.
I moved down to the Gulf coast and it's a different animal.
I mean the,
the depth and breadth of poverty in the Gulf coast and the southern part of the
United States is just extraordinary and it's been very hard to get people to,
um,
want to really take it on.
And really address these,
these poverty related diseases,
do you think?
What do you think the cause of it is?
I mean,
if you've,
you've studied this for quite a while.
What the cause of the neglect?
Yes.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know what,
you know,
is it something about American exceptionalism or something?
Like we just don't want to admit we have poor people.
Uh,
I don't know.
You know,
I wasn't the first to come up,
you know,
to raise this issue about poverty.
When I was in high school or junior high school,
I was forced to read a book and at the time I didn't care about it.
It was called the other America.
It was written by,
uh,
fantastic,
um,
social activist named Michael Harrington.
Um,
who was,
uh,
I think someone told me is a very devout Catholic actually.
And so,
and he wrote this book called the other America talks about the hidden poverty
off the road.
And the actual number of people who live in extreme poverty hasn't changed since
that book was written in the early sixties.
That book was helpful was,
but help Linden first Kennedy than Lyndon Johnson launched the war on poverty in
1964.
I dusted off that book and it's still,
it's still works today.
And that's how I start out talking about my book blue marble health about that
book the other America by Michael Harrington.
Yeah.
That,
that is a very strange thing.
Our acceptance of these communities.
And I mean,
I've always said that if you want to make America a better place,
the best thing to do is not invade other countries or intervene.
The best thing to do is try to rebuild these impoverished communities.
Yeah.
Well,
Gandhi,
Gandhi once said,
a civilization as judged by the treatment of its minorities.
And we're not by that criteria.
We're not doing so well.
You know,
the,
um,
we,
our country was visited by the United Nations special repertoire on poverty and
into 2017 and his numbers came up with,
we have 19.4 million Americans who live in what's called extreme poverty.
That isn't half the U S poverty line.
And roughly around 5 million Americans living on less than $2 a day.
The same benchmark you'd use for global poverty everywhere million.
Yeah.
And,
and guess what,
those probably all having neglected tropical diseases.
Five just,
just like,
just like those living in extreme poverty in Africa and there are 5 million
people living on $14 a week to $2 a day.
Yeah.
That's insane.
The University of Michigan Center on poverty is also shown that we have a,
I forget the number,
2.7 million families living on less than $2 a day,
which is probably about the same as the 5 million number.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
And again,
this is not a topic that is very popular.
I mean,
when,
when you see presidential debates,
this is,
this is not something that comes out now.
Nobody talks about it.
And again,
even for disease,
I mean,
what are the diseases we hear about Ebola and La Diseases like that.
And,
uh,
sometimes some of my frustration I say,
you know,
were,
these are imaginary diseases and yet here we've got widespread diseases of the
poor in the u s and the lights go out.
Do you remember when that woman came back from Africa and she was a nurse and
she had been,
uh,
some in some connection contacted with Ebola.
She didn't have it and they wanted a quarantine area.
Oh yeah.
And they,
they stuck around in some cabin on the airport or something.
Crazy is terrible.
Yeah.
What did you think about that?
I just thought it was so cruel.
And uh,
is it just a,
an ignorance of how it's transmitted?
How is it transmitted?
Well,
actually Ebola,
you know,
it turns out is the opposite of measles.
Measles is one of the most contagious diseases known.
It has a reproductive number of 12 to 18.
What that means,
if a single individual gets measles,
12 to 18,
others get it because the virus hangs around in the environment and it's so
easily transmissible.
Hangs around like if you touch this table.
That's right.
Or even in the,
even in the atmosphere.
So I'm,
and that's why you get these really large measles outbreaks like you're seeing
in Washington state.
Um,
and the,
and usually those are infants under the age of 12 months,
not yet old enough.
They vaccinated.
Those are the ones who I end up hospitalized and sick.
The,
um,
Ebola is just the opposite.
He ball is a reproductive number of two or three.
So unless you're taking care of a dead or dying,
he bowled a patient or someone who's recently died cause it's only towards the
end stage of the disease that you really get large numbers of virus particles
and the body,
you're not going to get Ebola.
So,
um,
the reason it's being so hard right now to contain in Democratic Republic of
Congo is not because it's so highly contagious,
it's just that the places is decimated by the collapse and infrastructure
associated with civil war.
So even though we have,
and now when Ebola vaccine,
it's hard to vaccinate everybody.
And how is it transmitted?
Uh,
Ebola by contact with fluids of somebody with,
with the bowl.
So it has to get into your tissue,
right?
Oh,
what else should we worry about?
You're freaking me out.
Well,
the point is a lot of these diseases are solvable if,
if we just put our mind to it.
So one of the things that were even aware of it,
and one of the things I say in the book is if,
because these diseases are so widespread among the poor and the g 20 countries,
if we could get the elected,
are the leaders of those g 20 countries together to g 20 summit and say we're
really going to do something about the neglected diseases in our own borders and
I'll include the United States.
We could get rid of two thirds of the world's poverty related neglected diseases
right off the bat.
Wow.
So a lot of it is political will or ignorance or lack of awareness and political
will.
Well,
it's,
it seems like in this country,
ignorance is a big part of it because a,
this is something I've thought about many times,
but I,
I didn't know about Chaga to know about a lot of these other diseases you're
describing.
Yeah,
no,
I mean,
so we,
we need to raise awareness about these.
That's why I'm so thrilled.
I'm so thrilled to come here because I've just amplified the number of people
who've heard of this concept of blue marble health is the name that I've given a
different name from global health to,
to separate,
separate it from the two.
Um,
so,
you know,
coming on here is so powerful in terms of amplifying that message.